gut gegeben wir uns weiter bleiben
balkon und geben weiß ja zu dir und du
hast uns ja auch ein cohen als jemand
mitgebracht was sich bewegt mich bewegt
2g und 3g 2g bereitet sich im moment in
deutschland aus wie ein ölteppich auf
mehr
immer größere flächen werden davon
erfasst
wer leben will und
mit spaß leben will der muss geimpft
sein oder gewesen sein
diejenigen die getestet werden und zwar
negativ getestet werden habe keine
chance da reinzukommen also restaurants
theater clubs bars
diskotheken in einigen ländern sogar
fußballstadien sind für die
nicht geimpften aber nicht corona
infizierten nicht zugänglich ganz anders
sieht es aus am arbeitsplatz aber gerade
geredet beider bei der bahn im bus im
flugzeug da gilt 3g wir sind die
geimpften die genesenen ungetesteten
gleichrangig unterwegs
diejenigen die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen aber frisch aktuell getestet sind
müssen natürlich auch arbeiten können
aber arbeiten müssen nicht zu hause
bleiben können mit dem öffnen
verkehrsmitteln fahren und sind
sozusagen mit den anderen gleich
gestellt ich frage mich frau hartes
warum nicht 3g auch in den anderen
bereichen und zwar überall gilt in den
gaststätten in den hotels in den in den
klubs in den diskotheken in den theatern
überall denn es ist doch nicht so dass
zweig gesundheitspolitisch betrachtet
einen vorteil hätte die geimpften sind
ja häufig selbst infektionsträger
während die frisch tagesaktuell
getesteten nicht geimpften geben keine
sind die sind sozusagen sicherer als die
geimpften sie dürfen aber nicht daran
teilnehmen das ist total widersinnig und
ich frage mich was ist der grund dafür
warum differenziert man so ich kann nur
eine erklärung dafür finden es geht
darum
die nicht geimpften gerade in der
vorweihnachtszeit so unter druck zu
setzen dass sie nämlich an den
eigentlichen leben am leben das spaß
macht nicht teilnehmen dürfen dass sie
sich dann doch am ende impfen lassen
weil sie dass sie einfach nicht
aushalten sie können ja in wahrheit
nicht viel mehr als arbeiten zu hause
bleiben
[Applaus]
und sich zurückziehen
das finde ich ist schikane 2 gegen die
deg ist schikane und ich halte es im
übrigen auch für verfassungswidrig denn
es widerspricht dem grundsatz der
gerechtigkeit der gleichwertigkeit der
personen und und negativ getestete sind
mit geimpften
gleichwertig weil sie ebenso wenig
infektionsträger oder gar krank sind
also lieber herges wir haben im sommer
auch 3g gefordert die beibehaltung der
3g regelungen aus nun aus dem frühjahr
und das entspricht auch nicht unserer
dna wer also die branche der
gastfreundschaft will niemanden
ausschließen jetzt ist die situation
aber so wie sie ist die mehrzahl der
bundesländer haben bereits zweig schon
eingeführt beziehungsweise jetzt in den
letzten 48 stunden beschlossen wir
brauchen jetzt eine klare kommunikation
kommunikation klare spielregeln und im
idealfall bundesweit also wir kommen so
nicht durch und deswegen also wir würden
auch lieber 3g machen aber es geht nicht
die zahlen explodieren die
wissenschaftler geben der politik der
landespolitik die beratung es kommt
jetzt zweig und wir haben nur die chance
jetzt geöffnet zu bleiben also dass es
keinen lockdown gibt dass wir das jetzt
konsequent umsetzen zweig wir haben 57
millionen menschen die haben mit ihrer
impfung bereits einen wertvollen beitrag
zur pandemie sind somit auf
die frisch getesteten sind gesehen weil
er mich nochmal ausmacht und wir stehen
wunderbar
ist so die politik hat das jetzt
entschieden es kommt und wenn wir
wirklich eine schließung der betriebe
verhindern wollen dann muss das jetzt
konsequent bundesweit einheitlich
umgesetzt werden wir können uns diese
flickenteppiche völlig unterschiedlicher
zugangsregelung wo sie würden von 2g
bitte also zweig kommt das dann ist gar
nichts mehr dran die restaurants machen
nicht mehr zum beispiel hier um die ecke
find ich persönlich hat einer draußen
beschrieben also das erst mal gehe ich
ja das ist ja aussagen der
wissenschaftler dass die tests nicht
sicher sind und so weiter das ist nicht
mein thema ich bin juristin und mir geht
es jetzt darum einen lock down für die
branche zu verhindern
und also glauben sie wirklich wir würden
lieber 3g machen aber es ist jetzt so
beschlossen und jetzt müssen wir das
auch konsequent umsetzen für eine
begrenzte zeit können wir keine
gastgeber für nicht geimpfte sein also
das ist so aber ich finde es auch
wichtig dass wir stärker auch noch
informieren aufklären die impfkampagne
ist jetzt richtig frau angereist das was
er gesagt hat ja durchaus charme und
entspricht ja durchaus auch der realität
also wir wissen selbst bei 2g ja nicht
ob jemand einen impf durchbruch hat wir
wissen aber beispielsweise wenn man sich
testen lässt als ungeimpfte oder als
geimpfter dass man eigentlich ein
relativ sicheres ergebnis hat und sagen
kann ist da jemanden positiv oder ist da
jemand negativ das heißt die frage ist
schon das wundert mich jetzt ein
bisschen dass sie da doch dann für die
branche sagen wir haben das jetzt
akzeptiert bezeuge was ist demenz
plötzlich heißt jetzt dürfen die
genesenen auch nicht mehr rein oder die
diebe geimpften auch nicht mehr rein
nach sechs monaten beispielsweise wie
wir mittlerweile auch gesehen am erste
krankenhaus die charité hat bis heute
morgen ein hinweis auf ihrer seite
gehabt dass künftig nur noch
besucherreihen dürfen deren test nicht
länger als den doppelten schon die
doppelte impfung nicht länger als sechs
monate hier ist der ist nachher von der
seite wieder genommen aber die nachfrage
aber dass keine frage also dass in den
krankenhäusern überwiegend die schweren
krankheitsverlauf war ein paar
bleiben
er betrachte ich meinen markus söder
gibt ja schon fast die ganze schuld ist
an die ungeimpften weiter wie sehen sie
das denn herr scheuer also mich besorgt
sicherlich die gesellschaftliche
situation und auch die stimmungslage im
land die ist sehr besorgniserregend aus
meiner sicht bar weil wir auch in den
krankenhäusern im übrigen was mir aus
meinem wahlkreis berichtet hat auch
pflegekräfte haben die von denen die
sich wirklich
als ganz ganz heftig impfgegner
darstellen selbst auf der
intensivstation
dass dort die an die leistungsgrenze
kommen die pflegekräfte und man menschen
nicht überzeugen kann aus einer angst
heraus oder aus einer
verschwörungstheorie heraus zum impfen
zu gehen trotzdem ist aufgabe von
politik zu vereinen gesellschaft
zusammen zu bringen und ich habe ein
herr jörges er so verstanden dass er
drei gehe relativ offen haben möchte
jetzt wenn man jetzt in die gastro-szene
geht heißt es ja auch veranstaltungen
die beispielsweise dieses haus macht
wenn ich das goldene lenkrad er denke
dann musste eigentlich jeder getestet
sein es muss man aufpassen dass man
keinen widerspruch haben das eine ist
natürlich die unbestrittenen auch im
durchbrüche wo er auch zweig unter dem
thema natürlich auch nichts mehr wert
hat wenn und durchbrüche sind aber rein
von der quote her muss man ja sagen also
ich habe elf
betten im klinikum passat auf unseren
zehn von ungeimpften belegt und einer
der im durchbruch in
der station nur mit toren ab acenta der
der mastplätze gestern heute ist auch
ein wand und diese quote müssen mal und
da bin schon
da ich bin kein wissenschaftler ja ich
kann nur sagen ja wir müssen ich würde
nicht spaß sagen in der jetzigen
situation hat keine irgendwie so richtig
wahnsinnig spaß aber ich bereue meine
frau haben die preußen gehe habe ich
spaß ja natürlich basis mit dem begriff
freude ausdruck gut wenn man diese
freude in der vorweihnachtszeit und mit
vielen vielen regeln hinbekommen dass es
wieder auch ein gesellschaftliches
miteinander
da wir an meiner stelle schon der appell
die gastro und hotel die szene wenn die
sagt zweig es ihnen es sind ist man ok
damit damit wir wenigstens einen grund
betrieb aufrechterhalten will dann muss
man
anmerken leider kurz weitergehen doch
wir sind euch allen noch jedes sollen
noch auf einen schreienden widerspruch
dieser verfluchten zweig regelung
aufmerksam machen wenn man zum friseur
geht muss man zweig sein der friese
lotte früher sehen selber muss es aber
nicht sein da weiß man gar nicht ob die
geimpft sind dass es so einer der vielen
neben widersprüche die sind doch absurd
zweig ist in wahrheit absurd